so if the reason you're leaving one job
is that it was toxic is a different
question than if you've left every job
because it was toxic if somebody came to
me and said every job they've ever had
was toxic
I would be a little bit suspicious you
know it's like the only common factor in
all my failed relationships is me which
is if every job you've ever been in was
toxic I'm thinking
were they though it was just the last
job that you're leaving
um what I would recommend is if somebody
says why are you leaving you a job you
say what I realize is I'm looking for an
environment that is caring and loving
and takes care of their people and I'm
looking for an environment that helps me
grow as a person and helps me grow as an
employee because my aspiration is to be
here for a while
um the reason I'm leaving the other job
is I realized that there was less
opportunity at that place which is why
I'm looking somewhere else